[Music]
look at that big grin on your face the
models were going bananas when they came
back here everybody was so excited how
do you feel now that it was exciting for
me from the jump just to be able to
display lingerie and the challenge was
just to figure out how to do it in a
different way because we've seen a lot
and it's fashion week so you know
everybody's expecting a runway show and
with lingerie gets tricky so I wanted to
do something that was special and new
and different and unique and I think you
managed to kind of accomplish that oh
yeah you did
we all got immersed into your savage
world lingerie is I mean it's so
intimate and so personal you know what's
that one piece of lingerie though that
you say every woman should have in her
closet if she needs to feel special I
mean is this still on the person what's
that one piece that Rihanna has to have
an arm I think yeah exactly because for
me it might not be the same for another
lady I think it has to be something that
makes you feel the sexiest weather I
mean what does that have those months
when I'm just like girl you're not gonna
fit into that thing you're gonna have to
do a little slick but fine the slip
works there's like me feel sexy and I'll
just do that
I think women's bodies are designed so
you knit me that they should just do
what makes them feel best and sexiest
I think the one question the biggest
question and conversation I have with my
girlfriend's especially the ones that
are in long-term relationships are
married and have kids or whatever is how
they keep feeling sexy and spicy in the
bedroom with their significant other how
much is lingerie a part of that equation
I think when lingerie is for you you
never lose your sexy because I feel like
a lot of times women do the lingerie
thing to get the ring and then they get
the ring and then it's like okay so
we're here the last piece you wore was
this one